it's all team welcome back to part
[ __ ] three hey not hurt I feel that
seriously damaged me something Jesus
Christ
there you go ah
they're everywhere if you press your uh
it's a protective shield it protect is
yes come on I need never [ __ ] die do
they there's a gun there maybe you need
it I don't really need it right now
you sure why doesn't he die
watch out for the night I threw I was
pretty epic move over you you're so
brave see pants yeah
you're my hero I died brofist brofist
mother's guy that don't sound that yagan
[ __ ] oh wait holy [ __ ] this gun
is awesome yeah I told you a shotgun but
I died instantly
get over half bro over here the time
like decreases every time that rhymed I
can't do [ __ ] wait I got some way oh god
oh god I'm done yeah me too this game is
fun like I don't know how they expect
people who never [ __ ] played an
offense before they play stop pre-press
mousewheel like press your mouse well
like I hold it all the right guy all the
freaking thing go I don't wanna hold on
I don't I guess no there's just one down
mom down why did you problem hey hurry
up and you need to brofist me I need
brofist bad Oh [ __ ] Nate
press Mouse lien by the way what Mouse I
don't got that memory for penises
everywhere be right [ __ ] back John me
don't even notice her Herpa derpa think
back I guess I don't know pres you know
the right guy I took the left guy okay
good now we both have exam ah I go down
like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I need a brofist and you better hurry
cuz I'm dying yeah I know oh I'm pressed
mouse with it got something you die from
like two bullets memory penis memory
fade ass Oh
so until welcome back for the [ __ ]
fifth time um someone told me you should
play fear three like oh really okay
let's go no wait wait wait wait come
back Mike damn it Chris mouse wheel
you like that oh oh yeah now this sauce
[ __ ] great
your fault let's camp camp in corner
camp in the corner camp in the Cunha you
want this corner yes Caleb upper corner
okay yes looks so [ __ ] jealous um
like there okay let's go
chrome oh not like I was I into then we
should just camp here yeah make them
come to us
yeah [ __ ] it might have brought us mad
me bro bro you mad bro come on bro bro
there you go again you stupid
ah I can hold open doors aha I can do
okay I'm slow memory generated oh so
let's do it
while I'm over here okay I can give you
shield I hope their health doesn't
regenerate Thanks okay I got one that's
pretty awesome bro stupid tradition yeah
let's just do that wait for slow-mo go
out shoot yeah let's do that entire game
maybe we'll cry yeah actually finish it
it would be like 50 episodes but it's
over oh look at me oh look at me are you
okay yeah you wanna go up there
jelly I didn't I think of that why this
guy from jülich on her dude I'm so like
in jelly
hello are there just hanging out there
for her her wait a sec okay I got
another one
he said I got a visual but none of us
are in sight oh we actually didn't die
when they threw an 8 with progress I
love how much you're helping me thank
you so yeah we made out
I forgot someone hey I have a few yeah
now you give it to me that sounds wrong
anyway should we hold that they don't
have a visual why are they lying to each
other where is he
bro shield is bro
keep giving it to me it's cool but now I
think it's safe
no it's not safe why did you go them
guess a lot of them are dead oh there is
I totally miss 1000 gonna hold on I
gotta be nah I'm taking one like you do
that move okay they're upstairs now I
see you oh [ __ ]
Hey
ah don't make me shoot you don't make
other everywhere make me shoot you yes
you are [ __ ]
where is he damn I like that sound I
bought the exploded
awesome shower from look at this blood
tissue blood I have my period I'm okay
let's go on uh yeah I don't wanna step
in my period you know yeah it's so
awkward I do that all the time and I
like oh and that's ah I'm dead I got him
sweet ah
why can't you just hold on where's that
I'd like to hold it back on the shotgun
I like her released I can aim down the
side okay without where are they
upstairs I'm shooting at him
boom [ __ ] oh damn oh [ __ ] I'm
holding em is up I'm spazzing em oh you
like that don't you years he loves oh
god don't die on me
please don't die on me I die don't you
die I lied on you professed
brofist krippfist brofist brofist yes we
class ah where are they someone inside
behind us holding I'm holding someone
else oh you're not supposed to do I know
that uh help me up me up me up me up me
up me up me up me up me up don't tell me
shut up okay I'm holding someone trying
to kill him I think I got a certain yeah
I got him there's just one gonna let you
throw Nate on you no oh no here done
gotcha
I'm on a truck oh come on back upstairs
who's talking oh man more no uh-oh oh
you're scared dude Oh some ammo pear
sweet I just I was in front of you and I
picked it up and you tell example there
I thank you kind sir problem should be
left leave people I mean open for no
wait look like you are everything
psychic link share or ste share it I
share why the [ __ ] did I share on wha
Master there you go oh you finger deaf
I should think about tough well I think
we're actually probably Singh now or
rola see no okay so part three done c4